para saber cómo es la numeración romana
basta con mirar el reloj y poner un poco
de atención en cómo van cambiando los
números en el 1 tenemos una i mayúscula
para el 2
tenemos dos para el 3 hay tres letras y
pero para el 4 tenemos una i y una v
si te fijas sólo tenemos letras
mayúsculas en el reloj la y la v y la x
con estas letras se escriben los números
del 1 al 12 que es el número al que
llega el reloj como viste una misma
letra se puede repetir hasta 3 veces y
después tenemos otro símbolo esto es
porque la numeración romana tiene
símbolos para los múltiplos de 10 y para
sus mitades es decir tendremos un
símbolo para el 15 10
50 100 500 y para el 1000 los números
romanos para cada uno son para el 1 es
la y para el 5 una v para el 10 una
equis para el 50 una l para el 100
una c
para el 500 una vez y para el 1000 una m
ahora cómo se organizan para formar
otros números vamos a seguir con el
reloj nos quedamos en el 4 que se
escribe con una y seguida de una v
esto significa que 5 -1 5 -1 es igual a
4 y si ya viste el 5 y el 6 en el reloj
te estás imaginando por qué se escriben
así el 5 es únicamente el símbolo de la
ub pero para el 6 a la v se le agrega
una y a la derecha para que sea más 1
516 ves es facilísimo a la izquierda se
restan y a la derecha se suman recuerda
que sólo puedes restar 1 y máximo puede
sumar 3 resolvimos este enigma romano
vamos a poner en práctica lo que
descubrimos como escribiría es el número
15 primero buscamos el símbolo más
grande para
nos alcance 15 es menor de 50 pero mayor
a 10 así que será el 10 colocamos una
equis que es el 10 romano nos falta
agregar el 5 y justo para el 5 tenemos
la v así que la ponemos a la derecha
para agregarle 5 al 10 y tener 15 esta
es la forma correcta para escribir el 15
y el 19 como lo hacemos podríamos tomar
el 15 y agregarle 41 a la derecha pero
un momento estamos repitiendo más de 3
veces un símbolo y eso está prohibido
vendrán los guardias de la antigua roma
en sus carretas para llevarnos por
traidores a las matemáticas mejor
busquemos otra manera vamos a colocar la
equis del 10 ahora cómo le podemos
agregar 9 pues podemos tomar otro 10 y
colocarle un 1 a la izquierda para
arrestarlo y así tener 9
entonces pondremos la primera equis
representando el 10 y la otra equis
tiene un 1 antes que la convierte de 9 y
así tenemos 19
es bueno que recuerdes que todos los
números que lleven un 4 o un 9
van a ocupar la regla de restar con el
símbolo a la izquierda el 40 404.000 así
como el 90 900 y 9000 irán restando 10
100 y 1000 vamos a escribir varios
números en el sistema decimal y su
equivalencia en la numeración romana
para que quede más claro el 530 es fácil
solo ponemos la d para el 500 y 3 veces
la equis de 10 para el 30 facilísimo el
2010 es muy pequeño porque sólo lleva
dos meses para formar el 2000 y una
equis para el 10 listo podría ser esto
todo el día el 420 requiere un poco más
de atención tiene un 4 así que usaremos
la regla de restar hacia la izquierda
para formar el 400 debemos restar 100 al
así que colocamos una de 500 con una c a
la izquierda para el 20
solo agregamos dos veces la equis vamos
a ver el setecientos noventa
para este número tomamos el 500 una vez
y dos veces el 100 para el 700 así que
escribimos d
sí
después tenemos un 90 así que usaremos
nuevamente la regla de resta a la
izquierda para el 90 prestaremos 10 al
100 por lo que colocamos una c con una
equis a la izquierda entonces nuestro
número queda como de c c x c vamos muy
bien para que te ganes el premio de
romano honorario sólo falta que conozcas
otro uso que le damos a los números
romanos en la actualidad además del
reloj que algunas operaciones en
capítulos de libros también podemos
escribir los siglos con este sistema de
numeración sabes en qué siglo estamos es
el siglo 21 y se escribe con dos equis
del diez y una y realizamos una
operación con números romanos para
responder cuántos siglos han pasado
desde el siglo 15 hasta la actualidad es
una resta muy sencilla de 21 menos 15
pero con números romanos se ve bastante
diferente
primero escribimos el 21 y luego el 15
con números romanos
vamos a ver 15 no se puede tomamos el 11
de arriba y menos 5 nos sobran 6 y luego
ya sólo tenemos 10 10 menos 10 es cero
así que colocamos un cero pero los
romanos no tenían un símbolo para el
cero entonces lo dejamos así ya quedó
han pasado seis siglos desde el siglo xv
hasta ahora es un poco diferente pero no
imposible de hacer y como en todo si
tomamos números más grandes se irá
haciendo un poco más complicado pero es
cuestión de práctica solo recuerda que
no hay un símbolo para el cero y debes
tener cuidado con eso al realizar
operaciones con números romanos a partir
de ahora ya sabes que esto no dice el ix
puede ser el 59 números romanos